I want to share with you a moment in my
life when the hurt and wounds of racism
were both deadly and paralyzing for me
and I think what I've learned can be a
source of healing for all of us when I
was 17 years old I was a college student
at Tuskegee University and I was a
worker in the southern freedom movement
which we call the civil rights movement
during this time I met another young 26
year old white seminary and college
student named Jonathan Daniels from
Cambridge Massachusetts he and I were
both part of a generation of idealistic
young people whose life has been ignited
by the freedom fire that ordinary black
people were spreading around the nation
and throughout the south we had come to
Lowndes County to work in the movement
and it was a non-violent movement to
redeem the souls of America we believe
that everyone both black and white
people in the South could find a
redemptive pathway
out of the stranglehold of racism that
had gripped them for more than 400 years
and on a hot summer day in August
Jonathan I joined a demonstration of
local young black people who were
protesting the exploitation by their
fair share croppers black sharecroppers
by rich land land holders who cheated
them out of their money we decided to
demonstrate alongside them and on the
morning that we showed up for the
demonstration we were met with a mob of
howling white men with baseball bats
shotguns and any weapon that you could
imagine and they were threatening to
kill us in the sheriff seeing the danger
that we face arrested us and put us on a
garbage truck and took us to the local
jail where we were put in cells with the
most inhumane conditions you can imagine
and we were threatened by the jailers
with drinking water that came from
toilets we were finally released on the
sixth day without our without any
knowledge without any forewarning just
out of the clear blue sky we were made
to leave and we knew that this was a
dangerous sign because Goodman Schwerner
and Chaney had also been forced to leave
jail and were murdered
because no one knew what had happened to
them and so despite our fervent
resistance the sheriff made us leave the
jail and of course nobody was waiting
for us it was hot one of those southern
days where you can literally feel the
payment seeping the vapor seeping out of
the pavement and the group of about 14
of us selected Jonathan Daniel's father
Morrow who had recently come to the
County Joyce Bailey
a local 17 year old girl and I had to go
and get the drinks when we got to the
door a white man was standing in the
door waiting his shotgun and he said
[ __ ] I'll blow your brains out and
before I could even react before I could
even process what was going on
Jonathan intentionally pulled my blouse
and I fell back thinking that I was dead
and then that instant when I looked up
Jonathan Daniels was standing in the
line of fire and he took the blasts and
he saved my life
I was so traumatized and paralyzed by
that event where Tom Coleman
deliberately with malicious intent
killed my beloved friend and colleague
Jonathan Merrick Daniel's on that day
which was one of the most important days
in my life I saw both love and hate
coming from two very different white men
that represented the best and the worst
of white America so deep was my hurt as
seeing tom coleman murdered Jonathan
before my eyes that I became a silent
person and I did not speak for six
months I finally learned to touch that
hurt in me as I became older and began
to talk about the southern freedom
movement and began to connect my stories
with the stories of my other colleagues
and freedom fighters who had who like me
had faced a deadly trauma of racism and
who had lost friends along the way and
who themselves have been beaten and
thrown in jail it is 50 years later many
people were beating the thrown in jail
others were murdered like Jonathan
Daniels and yet we are still we're still
as a nation
mired down in the quicksand of racism
and everywhere I go around the nation I
see and hear of the hurt and I asked
people everywhere tell me where does it
hurt do you see and feel the hurt that I
see and feel I feel and see the hurt and
black and brown people who everyday feel
the vicious volley of racism and
everyday have their civil and human
rights stripped away and the people who
do this use stereotypes and myths to
justify doing it everywhere I go I see
and hear women who speak out against a
long story towel against men who invade
our bodies these same men who then turn
around the same men who promote racism
and then turn around and still our labor
and pay us unequal wages I hear and feel
the hurt of white men after betrayal of
the state by the same powerful white men
who tell them that their skin color is
their ticket to a good life in power
only to discover as a circle of
whiteness narrows that their tickets
have expired and no longer carry
first-class status
now that we've touched the hurt we must
ask ourselves where does it hurt and
what is the source of the hurt our
proposed that we must deep we must look
at deeply into the culture of whiteness
that is a river that drowns out all of
our identities and drown us in false
uniformity to protect the status quo
notice everybody
I say of cultural whiteness and not
white people because of my estimation
the problem is not white people instead
it is the culture of whiteness and by
culture whiteness I mean a systemic and
organized set of beliefs values
canonized knowledge and even religion to
maintain the hierarchical over and
against power struggle structure based
on skin color against people of color it
is a culture where white people are seen
as necessary in friendly insiders while
people of color especially black people
are seen as dangerous and threatening
outsiders who pose a clear and present
danger to the safety and the efficacy of
the of the culture of whiteness
listen to me and see if you can imagine
the culture whiteness as a dehumanizing
process that melts away all of our
multiple and interlocking identities
such as race class gender and
sexualities so that we so that unity is
maintained for powering I believe
because I know and believe that
whiteness that the cultural whiteness is
a social construct each of us from birth
to death are socialized in this culture
and it marks people of color also and it
makes people of color like white people
vote against our interests
some of you might ask and write students
always tell about your hard assignments
some of you might ask and rightfully so
how do we fix this
it seems so all powerful and
overwhelming I believe that we must fix
it because we cannot humanize our future
if we continue to be complicit with the
culture of whiteness each of us was
could connect with our authentic selves
with our authentic ethnic cells and we
must connect with the other aspects of
our activities and we must move other
the constructs of whiteness brownness
and blackness to become who we are at
our fullest our collective how do we do
this I believe that we do this through
our collective narratives and our
collective narratives must contain our
individual stories how the arts
spiritual reflections literature and yes
even drumming it must be a collective
telling because individual stories has
create a paradigm where we are pitting
one story against another story these
different models that I have talked
about tonight I think are essential to
providing us a pathway out of the
quagmire of racism and I want to talk
about another very important model and
that
is redemption I believe that movements
racial justice must be redemptive rather
than punitive and yes I believe that we
must provide the possibility of
redemption for everyone and we must be
willing despite some of the Vil triolic
language that might come from from those
very people who oppress us I think that
we must listen to to them and try to
figure out where do they hurt we must do
this I believe because our redemption is
tied into their Redemption and we will
not be free until we've all been
redeemed from unredeemed Avenger the
challenge is not easy
and then the technological society it
grows even more complicated because
often we use technologies to perpetuate
the very values of racism that we
indulge in every day we use technology
to bully to perpetuate hate speech and
to degrade each other's humanities and
so I believe that if we're going to
humanize the future we must design ways
to use technology not to degrade us but
to elevate us so that we could live in
to the fullest our contract capacities
and I believe that technology must
provide us larger vistas so that we
might engage with each other and we'll
be on the segregated spaces that we live
in every day of our lives I believe that
we can achieve this if we set our minds
and hopes on the prize the question
before us tonight is very serious
it is do you want to be healed do you
want to be healed do you want to become
whole and live into all of your
identities or do you want to continue to
cannibalize your multiple identities and
privilege one identity over the other do
you want to join a long line of
generations of people who believed in
the promise of America and have the
faith to build democracy
do you want to live in to the fullest of
your potential I certainly do and I
believe you do too
let me just say quite seriously I
believe in you and despite everything I
still believe in them in America I hope
that this offering that I've given to
you tonight that I've shared with you
tonight will provide redemptive pathways
so that you might clean the fullest of
your identity and become a major
participant in humanizing not only the
future for yourselves but also for our
democracy
[Applause]